[Music]
today we're gonna talk about a subject
that's interesting to everybody in the
chess world I hope and that is the
question of nakamura lives in st. Louis
Sakura Nakamura and has been as high as
number 3 in the world a lot of burning
questions to people in the United States
is will Nakamura ever become a potential
world champion where we ever play that
World Championship match probably
against Magnus Carlsen and fight to
become number one in the whole world
Macklemore seemed to have a lot of
troubles against Carlsen in the past his
score is just wretched he hasn't won a
single game except blitzer rapid so he
came very close recently and that's one
of the games that we're gonna talk about
today he also did decently against
Magnus in his there outing here at the
Sinquefield cop and he credited that
partly to his new style choice here he
actually wore sunglasses during the game
apparently he was a little psyched out
by his arch-nemesis number one in the
world by a large margin and he wore
sunglasses to the game and he drew both
games I'm drawing comfortably with the
black pieces which was particularly
impressive
I'm actually here in st. Louis I'm also
partly to play poker which I'm gonna
start as soon as I'm done my residence
he's dead so I thought this was kind of
an appropriate send-off to show this
picture I was doing commentary for that
event actually and we were sunglasses to
that game as well so that's me
just dressed up a little bit so and also
not just in over the board have the have
you know Carlson and Nakamura kind of
gone off also in interviews which I find
pretty interesting you know a lot of the
top players when they're asked about you
know their main competitors there
they're really professional about it
they say I have most respect for my
opponent I think they're awesome
you know they can beat me on any given
day I'm gonna try to win that
see like a lot of things like that
people being very respectful and nice
whereas between Carlson and nakamori
it's not exactly the same
in fact Nakamura referred to Carlson as
the Sauron HS and said that he was gonna
have to take him down one of these days
I actually haven't seen Lord of the
Rings myself so I'm sorry if I butchered
that pronunciation but I was trying to
channel another very frequent Grand
Master in residence here at the club
yeah sir Sara Juan which I think it
would I should have just said that that
would have been closer right so anyway
Magnus is response to this thing by
Nakamura the statement to Nakamura on
his reddit ma at AMA ask me anything
was I might be more disturbed by this
comment if I ever saw the Lord of the
Rings or if Nakamura was a stronger
player that was pretty awesome anyway
let's take a look and of course those of
you might know that Nakamura has one of
the most uncompromising styles in the
world so he kind of goes up and down a
lot I said he was number three in the
world quite recently I think just a few
months ago he's already dipped as you
can see on this light chest waiting list
he's already dipped to number eight
which is unfortunate when you really
like to see him up there and in the top
spots I for one am a big Carlson fan big
Aronian fan I like a lot of these guys
but I just think it'd be really good for
chess in America if Nakamura worth to be
in like those top few spots so anyway
here is his biggest chance where he came
extremely close to doing what he had
never done before and we'll take a look
at this game pretty quickly because I
actually want to show you one other
Nakamura highlight so Nakamura wearing
sunglasses in that game I don't think
you heard him in this game but he's
known in general to be a very double
edged player so you'll see one
characteristic in this game that you see
when players want to play fighting chess
you can't always force it but what
Nakamura did here was he managed to play
a line that would result in a queenside
castling and
when you cast him on the queenside the
game becomes very double-edged ray and
he started with this line f3 so he's
kind of already signifying that he's
gonna play like a more sharp line
against the nimzo-indian error been
feingold in the audience so what used to
play Queen c2 normally I'd move for all
right so yeah so Grandmaster fine go to
the audience a big fan of the move Queen
c2 and usually not following it up with
queenside castling that's pretty rare
exactly I mean honestly you don't see
queenside castling a lot in d4 openings
for logical reasons I know we're of all
different levels I think we've got
players all the way up from all the way
from Grandmaster - I don't know I'll be
generous and say 1600 there you go
anyone who's under that's just instantly
been upgraded to 1600 we got a couple um
poker players in the audience too and
one of them's an expert so there you go
we got f3 so after d5 we see this line
where Magnus now can take on c3 but
instead he decided to retreat the bishop
with e7 so Bishop takes c3 being
slightly more common and not come where
at grabbing the big center with E for
that's usually like the battle for efore
it's usually the whole thing about the
names up so f3 of course is a bit of a
weak and a move but it does immediately
grab the e4 square and now for those of
you who don't know that theory any
guesses and what black plays here if you
know the theory it you know you know the
theory but v e5 yes II five is the move
that was played here it's a good move
the idea is that White's just not going
to get a lot if he takes this pawn after
the Queen trade and Knight g4 it's gonna
be very fine for if you you know if we
take this Queen off and you take with a
knight this hangs and if you take with a
king we see that Knight g4 is hitting on
this and hitting on that and it's a
definitely adequate for black not
winning for black but adequate so
instead Nakamura of course played d5 and
now this is kind of the idea that when
you play the pawn on e5 you can get some
control over the dark squares so Bishop
c5 and for what it's worth this game's
really long so I'm gonna go from some of
it a little bit quicker otherwise we'll
never get to Nakamura's win which would
be such a bad beat for him we only show
his terrible haha might happen want to
see I mean I feel like winds through the
anon game so after castles Knight f3
Bishop g4 we see now that white is
preparing to Castle queenside right and
you don't see this a lot in d4 openings
because the king is a lot area here with
all these squares but in this particular
position it's not why it also has a lot
of control so it's not going to be that
easy to kind of break through and punish
us for that and meanwhile we're really
ready and well set up to start an attack
of our own so in that Kimura I felt like
it was well worth it to have his King
exposed like this in order to make the
game more exciting and perhaps score his
his first victory against his nemesis so
now 92 attacking this Carlsen played c5
and now what move do you think nakamura
play here what's that you played here
no he did not play that let's see why
didn't he play that right away think
well yeah that's for sure I mean but I'm
looking like for the tactical it looks
like looks like like what Blake Black's
gonna get like quite a lot of play here
much more than in the game I mean there
should be like a decent amount of
compensation
well yeah Queen b6 and 95 it's coming
yeah so Carson wanted to kind of keep
more control in the position instead
because he really does have a lot of
control with the pawn on d5 it really
prohibits black from doing much so
instead white decided to kind of get
going with his attack so you could have
played h4 but instead of h4 you played
g4 yeah so he's gonna try to play both
moves like g4 an h4 and now Carlsen
played a5 so he's trying to kind of get
a grip on things here perhaps play a
four it's a moment and get some of the
major pieces in now what do you think uh
Nakamura played he didn't even have six
you can't like to take on f6 if he has a
really good reason but generally he what
he one two maybe wait for the right
moment because keeping this bishop will
be kind of cool getting in effect and
keeping the bishop alive just cuz it's a
it's a great attacking piece bishops
generally are usually when you pass so
Queen side at some point there's a key
move you like to make yes exactly King
b1 they also call this sometimes the
Grand Master move because Grand Master's
play it at all sorts of like strange
times that might seem weird because
there's all sorts of exciting things
going on in this position and they take
a timeout to play King view on but
really it it's safer on b1
and there's a lot of reasons why
Nakamura is gonna find it useful I have
this King here including one that's a
little bit more unusual which we'll see
in a minute
now besides king b1 and h4 what are some
other things that white probably wants
to do in this position what do you think
he wants to do with this Knight you
think he wants to take this bishop off
on d4 do you have other plans for this
night
yeah well this looks like a very strong
square for the knight right Knight to f5
because on that square it'll really
coordinate well with this bishop to
create an attack on this King so King me
one
and now after work to a six-night g3 was
played trying to get that brutal Knight
f5 move in and notice that if black
could ever played eight six in this
position this Knight f5 who would even
stronger so that's another example of
how you always want to like think about
it when you play a move like h6
now I'm really harping on Origen sorry
I'm his move h6 earlier but it's
definitely you still a possibility in
some variations because it's forcing but
you really got to make sure that you're
gaining enough for the weaknesses that
you're creating so here instead we saw
g6 to try to just like stop Knight to f5
since it's such a strong square you know
what do you expect what do you expect a
nakamori well I already showed you so
why do you think Nakamura played h4 just
to continue with the attack right now a
four
now what nothing'll has a lot of good
continuations in this game but I'm h5 is
one possibility you could also kind of
try to increase his tack in the game he
actually played work to h2 another
possibility is to play Bishop to h6 so
he's got a lot of interesting attack
kneeing continuations you played rock h2
kind of you notice in this position even
though and that can whereas a great
attacking player he also shows some
patience in this game yeah I thought
that a Bishop h6 here was interesting
because notice that if he plays rook to
e8 here what can white do so I think
this move was kind of tempting well I
mean we could always look at these crazy
sacrifices because our position is it's
so strong but there's a move here that's
just much more direct than that that
worked in really good tandem with Bishop
h6 sticking that rook on it because when
we play Bishop h6 he only move to
protect the rook is rook e8 right yes so
g5 here looks quite strong because
before in the night could have retreated
back to e8 and now I must go to h5 where
we could just take it right so that was
another option for a Nakamura
but honestly his position is very good
now as well so he's going for like the
kind of slow attack here and now we see
the the bishop coming backwards and he's
gonna get his pawn storm going you
decided to play g5 right away he could
also probably play h5 right away they
both look really strong a lot it that's
why the Knights so good on g3 because
those of you who play the dragon or
probably familiar with situations where
the knight can blockade on 85 and it's
kind of hard to continue the attack
whereas here look how beautifully this
Knight stops that right so the knight on
G 3 even though it didn't get to go to
f5 ended up becoming a really important
piece here so the knight goes back to it
you know nakamura of course follows it
up with h5 he's trying to yank that
file-open
not
I mean sorry Carlson getting some
counterplay on b2 but you see like his
counter plate just seems a lot more
awkward
we called when a Bennifer does a
commentary here at the st. Louis chess
club we call this rook up and over that
we saw they say it's a rover and a lot
of times it's really an effective way to
get your works in the game without
cranking the file open with a pond but
here it just does seem like just
visually look at White's attack and look
at blacks attack right just doesn't feel
like black has enough going on right and
also y can just stop this attack with
what move what can why you play here to
prevent rook takes B to Jack just simple
just a simple move yeah Bishop c1 and
that was also one of the reasons earlier
that we might not have traded that and
also a reason why having the the King
one be one is nice because if it was on
c1 we wouldn't have Bishop Siwan so
Bishop c1 protecting this pawn very well
challenging us want to come up with some
better some better ideas here is black
sand better counter-attacking ideas so
it worked be three hitting our queen
queen g4 now Knight b6 getting one more
piece in now question why would it what
do you think I mean in in all these
types of attacking positions you always
want to look at all the foreseen
variations so you know at this point
you're looking at stuff like H takes g6
right away right trying to see if that
works out or not and one of the biggest
mistakes that players make when they get
an attack like this is they rush it then
once they build it all up and that's why
it's good to study games of great
players like Nakamura so you see like
how even though he's a slashing
attacking player he really takes his
time to make sure that the attack is
going to be successful because let's say
you do play H takes g6 right away well
it's gonna work out really well if your
opponent happens to play H takes g6
right cuz then you just get to go we're
just play Queen h4 and it's like over
our resigns right whereas because were
threatening in Queen h8 and Queen eight
seven mate and if you you move your F
pawn we're just gonna play Queen a chain
and work h7 also meeting so instead
of course black would take was what here
we would take with the up pawn right and
now it's like not so clear you've gained
in this position right because Queen e6
check black seems to be holding on by a
thread when they play Queen f7 in
general in chess there's a lot of talk
about how important it is to bring the
Queen into the attack which is very true
if you trade Queens and chats a lot of
times your attacking chances plummet or
disappear off then but there's not as
much attention paid to the fact that
getting the Queen into the defense is
equally important right if you can get
the Queen into the defense often that
really just like stops White's attack in
the tracks so not Kimora's not gonna
rush with that instead he's gonna take
it slow and try to get another piece
into the attack by playing Bishop b2
which piece is he gonna get into the
attack not the bishop but the work on d1
right so very nice play by Nakamura so
far and seems like he's just really from
the opening he's gotten like a great
position and he has managed to nurse it
pretty well alright so now we are work
to da chuan getting that extra piece in
and now Carlsen
tried to make things really complicated
by playing Bishop takes b2 because it
just looks like he's gonna get butchered
if he doesn't right I mean if he doesn't
try something here just let the threats
seem very overwhelming these two major
pieces lined up and now H takes g6 is
certainly coming because if you take
back now we have the rooks coming to to
get you as well right so that's not
gonna work out so well we even have like
some pretty possibilities like we just
make like some random terrible move by
black we can think about doing things
like well that would be really terrible
I'm trying to make me I'm trying to make
this a two rook checkmate I don't know
if that's gonna quite work but I'm
Queenie six Jack looks good I mean we're
just winning we can even just win the
night and work eight seven stuff is
coming up as well so Carson felt like it
was the moment to try whatever he could
right desperate desperado if you will
mister takes me to this should take c2
and now Knight takes e4
but notice that Nakamura is where Karen
h2 is also performing this defensive
function as well as an attacking
function is very important and now we we
see this position which so he can't you
can't take back with it with the pond
with either pond both of them seem like
it's just going to be devastating for
black we could take a quick look at that
but he just decided to play commune b6
getting counter play and now what do you
think Nakamura did there was actually a
nice article about this on chess life
online by the really great Australian
writer Ian Rogers where he made this
whole game into a musical actually there
was just a jazz concert over across the
street at the World Chess all the same
and I think when knocking where I played
this move he said I think I might win
this time is there a song like that I
might finally win what the song was it
was very applicable to this position and
there was like 30 or 40 songs that he
tried to kind of like explain this game
just because there is so much drama in
it no Melissa would take a look at G f7
so g f7 work takes f7 also seems like
definitely a possibility here and if
queen c8 check yeah I think we can so
you got stuff going on over here so now
we can go here yeah so I think if you're
going to go for this line get one more
piece into the attack and we're still
covering seems like we're still covering
here after after Brooke takes B to track
we're still covering this rank here so
you don't have any like quick checkmates
on us and meanwhile we're gonna bring
our knight to f6 and Queen to c8 in
conjunction and trying to meet you on h7
so this would be a possibility too so I
guess what this shows is that Nakamura I
just had lots of nice possibilities
there
so instead g7
and yeah so g7 is kind of an important
move just King can't take because if the
King takes we just take back on h7 check
and we're gonna win your queen or mate
so instead black had to move his work
away and now black has to wait has to be
a little bit careful like what happens
if you plays or takes a chum in here
okay so retakes b2 and now if King a1
somebody what's that yeah so work to a
to check and then Queen B to mate so
very double-edged so it looks like you
know Carlson has gotten something and
that he has some like threats that were
lying there in the position of course
Nakamura is not going to miss that and
that's why his work is like chilling on
h2 to stop all that kind of stuff
so instead Nakamura played Queen to h4
to attack a checkmate directly right and
continue to keep the defense of this
Bishop here on b2 okay so we looked at G
takes f7 check which means promising as
well and then in the game g7 check
happen and then Ken in the audience is
asking about G takes h7 check a good
question because if we play King g7 that
looks pretty terrible right so probably
will play King h8 here and now it looks
like we're being actually helped by the
fact that that pawns there right because
it's shielding us from the attack which
is an interesting defensive you know
kind of motif in chess that sometimes
when your opponent's attack is crashing
through you can actually stop it by
letting them take your bonds a very
typical thing that happens in the dragon
as well you see that all the time so
instead we were here in this position
and knock and where to play Queen h4
threatening checkmate and continuing to
defend this against these mating threats
on b2 so after work be to convene a one
of course none of this work a2 stuff
works anymore because we're continuing
to cover the rank so in
stead carlson treated on h2 and now he
has to defend against g6 right so he
played queen g6 so this is obviously you
know bad news now his attack has led to
nothing and he was using his queen as a
defender which I did just say was good
it's good if you get your Queen into the
defense but in this situation the queen
is very awkwardly placed it doesn't
really have a lot of spaces to move to
right especially after Nakamura is next
move
so yes it's good to get the Queen into
the defense if it works right like
that's I'm sure that'll be useful it's
it's anything that I any like Maxim that
you say in chess like it's good to
centralize if it works it's good it's
good to get your Queen into the defense
just make sure that it's good but up
seriously yeah this is I definitely an
exception there that Carson was forced
to do this but it doesn't work out so
well for him so how do you think white
plays here
yeah we've been kind of like wanting to
play Knight to fi for a long time and
now finally we get it and to boot were
threatening a 97 check I'm just just
working the king and the Queen so Magnus
had to play work to e8 to prevent that
so he seems like he's totally on the
defensive that being said working in his
favor the fact that Nakamura has very
few pieces left in the board right we're
working with just the Queen the knight
in the rock so we have to be really
precise to like close the deal here
right and after Queen to g4 what do you
think White's idea is here it's White's
idea here what's that yeah Nikki yeah
just work to h6 in that and that's what
I was saying about the Queen in the
defense that like this Queen the
defensive position does not look as
attractive as many because if we play a
good tummy move here for black work to
h6 will just simply trap the Queen right
so Carlson had to move his Queen again
and now this is where things started to
fall apart a little bit for Nakamura
so you played Queen to h3 when you went
back to g6 obviously he didn't want to
draw there so they've repeated this
position one
or I'm sorry they didn't really because
it was on h4 before right
yeah sorry they they couldn't have it
looks similar it sound exactly the same
so now this is where we're Nakamura I
made a blunder how bad do you think the
blunder was Ben because I feel like a
lot of people in line we're saying it
was like one of the most grotesque
blunders they'd ever seen but that of
course they're using their engines to
support that and so to me it seems like
okay obviously at that high of a level
it's a big blunder but I think it's like
it's not as obvious as people were
making it out today would you agree with
that yeah because I was I saw this movie
you were like amazing Wonder and I like
I think amazing blunder I think like
Kramnik kang you're made in one to keep
frits or something you know or like
there are like a lot of or garry
kasparov against deep blue i just used
to a computer examples but there are
definitely some blenders that super GM's
make and i just don't think that this
ranks in the top ones because it's like
a little bit difficult to see
yes there's a beautiful although queen
f1 is good even if you don't see the
computer land because queen queen f1 is
just a really really sweet move here
it's just like such a cool-looking move
because you're moving your queen
backwards which usually seems like the
opposite of what you wouldn't want to do
to attack but the nice thing is you have
all these extra threats now because
you're coming in again possibly with
work h6 at the right moment and you're
also attacking this and f7 is going to
be under fire if you play Knight to HX
right he tries to move his queen away so
that this this was like the this was
like the star move here and then for
instance of Carlsen were just to play b5
white here had a spectacular way to
finish although I think that even if you
didn't find the spectacular way there
are also just like prosaic moves that do
pretty well here as well but so yeah
this crazy move or cakes h7 which been
mentioned so what's the idea let's uh
let's look so go from let's try to
calculate it to the end
so somebody try to do some analysis for
me of why this is kaput
right so if Kim takes h7 just Queen h1
can J Queen h8 Mei right so what happens
if we take 2 h7 what's a full line there
so Knight h6 king takes you seven yeah
so you got to try to analyze it so try
to analyze it to the end so we're we're
yet now we're at Queen takes h7 so this
is the aniline law analysis and Knight
to Knight to h6 check here so now if kim
g7 so Queen takes f7 check and then we
have to go king page 8 and then q g7 so
now we were close to me Queen f7 check
King h8 and then Queen f8 right so yeah
so hon say that this it's over right so
a very cool line but regardless nakamora
in this position played d6
which is a really bad move but you kind
of feel sorry for him because it's like
very understandable why somebody would
play that move to me I mean it looks
like really I don't know it looks really
strong in first glance because your idea
is that if they take twice on d6 you
play Queen 87 mate right but what the
problem here is which is I think
difficult for a lot of humans to see is
that black in the meantime they've
gotten so many pawns and whites King is
relatively weak that white really needed
to find the hammer blow and keep doing
pleat control over the position right
like I said earlier that that point on
d5 kept total control because black
wasn't getting any counter play because
the files are all closed in order to get
the desperate bid for counter play that
he got which got him back into the game
he had to pull up a rover rook up and
over because there were no lines open to
him right so this is kind of changing
the story and black just makes this very
elegant move here instead of taking on
d6 getting checkmate ahead he just plays
rook to d8 and now suddenly you see like
if Nakamura is not mating
suddenly your you've got we've already
got six pawns to four it looks like this
one's gonna hang and this one might hang
and your King now is under fire so well
I guess you have that level I'm sure
it's a blender I just thought it was
exaggerated from the well yeah yeah
ninety-eight here would be like the
closest would be would be the try and
then whites a little bit better right
it's winning yeah better so nice you
obviously that's a weird move
but again that's supposedly the best
move Knight c4 instead was play like the
more like normal-looking move but
problem isn't Knight gets kicked around
now after a queen takes pawn and
actually Nakamura ended up losing this
game which was like really
obviously was very emotionally difficult
because he seemed to have such a
dominant position it just shows like how
something can just like slip from your
grasp against such a great player
the thing is weaker players and Carlsen
would just completely collapse like many
moons ago you know and that's the thing
like some people say that Carlsen style
is like a little bit hard to define that
it's just about making good moves and I
do think like his fighting spirit is one
thing you can pinpoint because a lot of
the time he doesn't get much from the
opening and he's still you know you saw
at the same field cop his amazing
fighting spirit so route d3 now kidding
c4 again and he ends up after Queen f5
he ends up picking up another pond yeah
because of the attack on the rook on h4
and now he just ended up winning this
game I mean this is a awful lot of pawns
to defend against right for just having
the one night so sad so I think we're
going to just like go over this really
quickly and so I can so I can atleast
show you the beginning of the anon game
as a counterpoint for a game where
Nakamura one and instead of losing and
such such tragic fashion because he is a
st. Louis player and he calls st.
Louis's home
so this is how the game ended yeah and
with another queen coming for Magnus
haven't seen that game before it was
kind of famous I mean it only occurred a
month ago
what February if I think early February
so it's been about two months so in this
game which were acting at a chance to
look at all of but I'll show you the
opening and the critical moment at the
end Nakamura was playing black this time
against machine on who he's done rather
well against indeed so the complete
opposite he's had a terrible score
against Carlsen and he's managed to do
well against and on so you imagine
there's some psychological element to
that right there's a lot of psychology
in chess not as much as there is in
poker but it's definitely underrated I
think especially at the top level where
you play the same people all the time
so you get this kind of like thing about
your score and your openings and
probably the biggest psychological
element in chess is before the game in
selecting the open ends and that whole
surprise element so in this game what
interested me it was there was a quote
here by Nakamura that objectively I
shouldn't even castlelong but I felt it
was very interesting I have a feeling it
was suspicious to say the least so
that's one of the reasons why even
though Nakamura you know has like a lot
of ups and downs and sometimes says it
says like funny things funny things to
say to put it in the most politically
correct way people you got to love him
because he's gonna top five players in
the world most of the time and he says
that he played this move even though he
thought it was bad jessica's he thought
it would make the game more interesting
I mean that's kind of rare at that it's
extremely rare at that level especially
because he's not doing it against a
lower rated player where you know feels
like he needs to win he's doing it
against one of the best players ever
right that's just very very awesome
for the fans at least so he queenside
castle here and again I mentioned
earlier that queenside castling leads to
such sharp positions where both sides
are attacking so we see that again in
this game that
both sides are gonna end up attacking in
the respective flanks your nan playing a
four how many people will prefer White's
position here how many people are
undecided how many people like black
after my speech
oh then legs both players black seems
like a square oh yeah yeah that is kind
of unusual like this like doubled pawns
phalanx here right here again sticking
it where the King position so so f6 is
we see these kinds of moves a lot in his
opposite side castling moves normally we
don't see the one move too often when
we're Castle kingside
but here we are trying to play g5 at
some point so now macklemore just
decided to go for it and make this this
wild sacrifice because he thought his
position was like pretty bad if you
didn't go for something like that I know
how do you think white plays here been
do watch all the major live yeah exactly
yeah I think thank you to was played
actually what did you think of the game
when it was being played is it hard for
you when you have like an American
playing against one of your old friends
you don't know who to root for a very
felucca correct responds we know been
rooting for someone but he's not telling
us who it is he doesn't want it to be
broadcast to youtube too or what like
12,000 subscribers or something and
growing so yeah I mean this is a good a
pretty complicated position to evaluate
because white it White's got the two
minor pieces verse the rook and in
general
attacking positions we prefer to have
the minor pieces but at the same time
blacks whites king is a bit open how
many people would prefer to be white at
this point yeah you you know that's what
you prefer to be black here despite
everything yeah I feel like black I feel
like black is probably I think it'd be a
non master level probably blacks doing
pretty well here because the King is so
exposed what's that yeah Nakamura been
said that NOC mores really good at
confusing positions yeah he does like
that although he he also knows how to
play like a solid position as well but
he's you see more and more that
sometimes he just plays like a pretty
solid opening so yeah again remember Ken
earlier you were talking about a
position where you want if you're trying
to play a six and ranked open the file
so sometimes the opponent can use their
pawns to stop it from being super ugly
right so now after b6 if a man were to
continue with a seven you could shield
our King using our King to shield from
further attack right so let's get to the
end of this game and see how Nakamura
won brilliantly so we can have a little
bit of fun exactly we got the rover in
this game too so basically black is
doing well in this game now and black
did well in the last game with a rover
so there you go rook up and over a way
to get your works into the attack so
taking on f5 preventing it now after
Queen takes fi we're renewing the idea
although I mean Knight e3 is possible
but we're gonna be able to continue to
attack with h5 and H for
all right Knight e3 Queen d7 and so now
he's using that King getting it out of
the way and so H fives just you know
kind of move that you're always playing
when your opponent with a Heather Knight
on g3 right try to hit try to get it out
of the way so of course you know now in
this position I mean one thing I always
try to tell people is about Queen trades
when you're
opponent offers you a trade of Queens
really the first thing you want to ask
yourself is about King safety so if you
your king is safer than your opponent's
you really want to lean against trading
Queens right because that usually takes
all the fun out of attack and that's
actually a contrasting principle to the
principle that works are usually good
and better at end games and in MO games
so I think Hiro Nakamura is strongly
more in favor of the other principle
considering that he's coming in with
this and with this possibility and this
king is here naked so I really like to
finish in this game so I'm going to head
over to that as you can see yeah yet
tell me about man I can't want to go
there that far ok so let's talk about
this position told me why your work
takes to you three is a good move
so if work takes you three if Queen
takes you three of course there's just
me the one right so what happens at
ponte c 3 so try to analyze to the end
of the game after after fkc 3 so worked
AC 3 we always look at all the capture
is pretty clear Queen takes e3 it's it's
a checkmate in 1 on g2 so after F takes
e3 what is the variation that Nakamura
had in mind and actually ended up
playing who said that yeah so Queen d2
and then how would white defend Queen f1
or Queen f3 and then what would black
play
well if we're if Queen f3 work to you
three is certainly a good possibility
but in the game actually white did play
Queen to f1 so I think after a Queen f3
work to you three is probably pretty
good yeah with the idea that this night
is pin so I can't take right and the
Queen of course can't take so if the
Queen goes back black can just play work
take to e3 and everything is is pretty
lovely there so instead though white
played Queen to f1
yeah he did play work ethic and actually
just a non-immediate really resign so it
just looks like totally over yeah is
everything is everything is falling
apart
III is falling b2 is falling and we're
coming in with our queen and our work
here so so two examples of nakamora
games one where is explosive attack kind
of like backfired on him and after it
just like one pretty big blender and
another one in which he played something
which he actually said he thought was
bad just in order to get an exciting
position
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]